nous sommes sur le point de perdre ses
forêts
elles sont littéralement sur le point
d'être entièrement détruite
des paysages de la Colombie-Britannique
complètement défigurée par les coupables
et au cœur de tout ça une entreprise de
la Grande-Bretagne qui veut encore plus
de bois canadiens
[Musique]
nous créons des emplois locaux directs
et indirects
notre produit remplace le charbon
produit c'est le granulé de bois nos
collègues de CBC se sont intéressés à
une entreprise qui en fabrique notamment
en Colombie-Britannique pour le brûler
de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique et
produire de l'électricité
ces entreprises affirme être vertes et
durables
mais ce n'est qu'un énorme mensonge
c'est une machine qui rapporte beaucoup
d'argent à quelques personnes grâce aux
subventions du Royaume-Uni et aux dépens
de la Colombie Britannique ici Marie
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
dans le nord de l'Angleterre une
manifestante force l'arrêt d'un train de
marchandise elle grimpe sur le toit pour
tirer la sonnette d'alarme et dénoncer
une industrie dont la plupart d'entre
nous n'ont jamais entendu parler
son cri du coeur est motivé par le
besoin effréné d'électricité au
Royaume-Uni le pays comme toute l'Europe
traverse une crise énergétique les
factures d'électricité des ménages ont
triplé depuis l'invasion de l'Ukraine ce
qui rend le pays encore plus dépendant
de la centrale électrique drive elle
brûle du bois transformé en granulés
provenant du monde entier cette
entreprise est si énorme qu'elle a fait
l'objet d'un reportage dans l'émission
méga shephers
55000 tonnes de granules de bois
un combustible essentiel pour la
gigantesque centrale électrique Drax la
plus grande du Royaume-Uni
[Musique]
la Colombie Britannique la
Grande-Bretagne a abattu ses forêts il y
a des siècles pour alimenter cette
centrale affamée drague achète du bois
en Colombie-Britannique les vidéos
touristiques de la province montrent des
arbres à perte de vue c'est cette image
qu'elle présente au monde
la Colombie Britannique super naturelle
[Musique]
mais quand vous survolez les terres à
partir de Vancouver le décor est bien
différent toutes ces tâches claires
étaient autrefois des forêts aujourd'hui
ce sont des coupes à blanc chaque arbre
a été abattu
nos collègues de CBC veulent donc savoir
d'où provient le bois que Drax brûle en
Angleterre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils arrivent à kennel juste à temps pour
la Foire d'été l'industrie forestière a
construit cette ville mais il est
difficile de ne pas sentir que les
choses ici ne sont plus qu'elles étaient
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Bob simsen est le maire de la ville
l'industrie forestière de la
Colombie-Britannique est en mode survie
il se regarde les uns les autres en se
demandant quelle sera la dernière usine
à résister
[Musique]
quoi ressemblait les forêts vu de
l'espace il y a 20 ans et voici à quoi
elle ressemble après une infestation
d'insectes ravageur le gouvernement de
la Colombie-Britannique a alors permis à
l'industrie forestière de se débarrasser
au plus vite de tous ces arbres morts ce
fut une véritable ruée vers l'or pour
l'industrie forestière à cette période
les séries Bourdonnais
[Musique]
nous n'avions jamais eu autant de
déchets de Syrie et comme il ne pouvait
pas transporter tout le bois nous nous
retrouvions avec des déchets de Bruce
comme jamais auparavant
l'industrie des granulés de bois est
arrivée en disant nous avons une
solution peu de gens savent à quel point
les granulés de bois sont réellement
utiles à quel point elles sont
essentiels pour nous fournir de
l'énergie cette vidéo promotionnelle
explique que les granulés sont fabriqués
à partir de sciure de bois provenant des
séries de même que des restes de coupes
nous utilisons les résidus des séries
mais aussi les branches ou les cimes
laissées après la battage ce sont donc
des déchets forestiers laissés dans la
forêt au dire de l'industrie des
granulés de bois elle rend service au
britanno colombien en utilisant les
résidus tels que les cimes des arbres et
les branches laissées par l'industrie
forestière
ce sont des granulés de bois
ce sont des granulés de bois et
effectivement le processus devait
consister à fabriquer ces granulés à
partir de déchets forestiers
mais 2020 sonne la fin de la manne de
l'exploitation forestière les coupa
blanc ont dévasté les forêts il y a
moins d'arbres moins de série moins de
déchets ce qui est un problème pour
draxerait s'il n'y a plus les résidus de
bois sur lesquels cette industrie s'est
bâtie comment l'alimenter et cette
industrie a commencé à se développer de
façon exponentielle
le gouvernement de la
Colombie-Britannique et de la partie
selon son ex Premier ministre John
organe le développement de l'industrie
des granulés de bois est une solution
gagnant-gagnant cela fait partie d'une
bio économique la croissante que
Monsieur organe s'est engagé à soutenir
davantage
to morfiler
en chef depuis longtemps en
Colombie-Britannique dernière Nicole
apparaît dans une vidéo de l'industrie
des granulés de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
trouver des marchés étrangers pour les
granulés de bois fait partie de la
stratégie de gestion forestière de DAE
Nicole
qui décident de l'utilisation de la
forêt et de ce qui est exploitable
elle ne croit pas en message du
gouvernement organe elle enquête sur
Drax et l'industrie des granulés de bois
depuis des années un jour elle découvre
un indice qui lui fait craindre qu'une
entreprise de granulés coupe des arbres
entiers
on explorait une zone de forêt pluviale
à environ une heure à l'est de notre
communauté de prince Georges
on est tombé sur un ruban des
signalisation sur lequel était inscrit
le nom d'une entreprise de granulés de
bois
semblait sur le point d'être exploité
[Musique]
Michel cornely fait alors des recherches
et apprend qu'une entreprise de prêt
Georges a obtenu un permis pour
transformer des pruches entières en
granulés et non seulement les cimes et
les branches
je ne pouvais pas le croire on n'avait
pas réalisé que certaines forêts
primaires allaient être exploitées et
que la plupart allait être transformés
dans des usines de granulés cette
industrie pourrait avaler toutes nos
forêts primaires restantes
c'est devenu notre plus grande crainte
quand nous avons compris que la
Forestière en chef elle-même en faisait
la promotion
Michel Cornelli amène au collège au cœur
de cette forêt
selon elle rien ne peut y être considéré
comme déchets
occidentale quel âge a-t-elle selon vous
il faudrait faire un carottage pour le
savoir
cet arbre a probablement plus de 200 ans
qualifié les forêts comme celle-ci
dominée par la pruche de moindre valeur
parce que le bois n'a pas vraiment
d'autres utilité
mais selon elle ces arbres constituent
un habitat pour les oiseaux et les
animaux ils sont essentiels à la
biodiversité de la forêt
elle voulait savoir ce que le
gouvernement de la Colombie-Britannique
avait donné à l'industrie des granulés
de bois
elle a donc travaillé en collaboration
avec un journaliste de Victoria ben
perfect qui a fouillé dans les bases de
données provinciales
ce sont toutes les données que j'ai
extraites de la base de données du
gouvernement provincial appelé le
système de facturation des récoltes ils
ont découvert que le plus grand
fabricant de granulés de bois de la
Colombie Britannique pinacle avait un
fait obtenu plusieurs licences
d'exploitation de forêt anciennes ou
primaires moyennant des redevances pour
les arbres coupés
de l'or
l'industrie des granulés de bois prétend
ne pas être intéressés par le bois des
arbres et ne vouloir travailler qu'avec
les résidus forestiers alors comment
vous expliquez ça
vous faites cette découverte et vous
comprenez que cette industrie qui dit
s'être bâtie sur la récupération des
résidus forestiers est en fait impliquée
dans l'exploitation forestière
qu'avez-vous fait ensuite nous avons
décidé de dénoncer publiquement ce qui
se passait en Colombie-Britannique
l'industrie des granulés de bois est
prête à se développer à grande échelle
pour y parvenir le gouvernement continue
d'autoriser l'exploitation des forêts
primaires cela doit cesser
il y a des gens vont se gratter la tête
et se dire est-ce que quelqu'un peut
m'expliquer vous êtes en train d'abattre
des forêts pour transformer ses arbres
en granulés et les brûler mais c'est un
retour au Moyen-Âge quand on allait
chercher du bois dans la forêt pour se
chauffer
[Musique]
voici la réalité de l'industrie des
granulés de bois en Colombie-Britannique
des rangées de bûches prêtent à être
coupés et expédiés outre Atlantique pour
être brûlées l'an passé en rachetant la
plus grande manufacture de granulés de
bois de la Colombie-Britannique Drax est
devenu le plus grand joueur de la
province et cette centrale électrique en
Angleterre a de gros besoins en bois
après la pause des Britanniques qui se
battent pour protéger nos forêts
c'est le plus grand émetteur de carbone
au Royaume-Uni c'est de l'écho
blanchiment une arnaque c'est un
gaspillage de fonds publics
vous le savez l'urgence climatique c'est
l'enjeu planétaire de l'heure alors on
est ici devant une industrie qui prétend
fabriquer une énergie propre avec un
carburant renouvelable du bois mais
attention l'enfer est parfois pavé de
bonnes intentions
la Colombie-Britannique est durement
frappée par les changements climatiques
inondations feux de forêt glissements
terre le Royaume-Uni n'est pas non plus
épargné le réchauffement de la planète
entraîne la multiplication des vagues de
chaleur mort mortelle
le Royaume-Uni a promis de s'attaquer
aux émissions de carbone et a déclaré
que la centrale électrique drague serait
une solution elle brûle du bois y
compris des granulés de bois provenant
de la Colombie-Britannique mais ces
promesses vertes font face à une
opposition déterminée
ce mouvement visant à freiner Drax gagne
du terrain
[Musique]
chacune de ces tours fumantes et plus
haute que la Statue de la Liberté nos
collègues souhaitent rencontrer des
personnes qui veulent faire fermer Drax
et ainsi sauver les arbres de la
Colombie Britannique
[Musique]
Mary dickensen et georving font partie
de la société axe Drax abattez
leur combat contre la plus grande
centrale électrique de Grande-Bretagne à
partir de la ville historique de York
ils sont jeunes sont idéalistes mais ils
ne sont pas seuls et leurs combats
prendre l'ampleur
le groupe drague c'est le plus grand
brûleur d'arbre au monde et le plus
grand émetteur de carbone au Royaume-Uni
seul un géant peut agir de la sorte
pour Mary dickensen cela signifie des
actions directes comme celles-ci peindre
des bâtiments à
l'aérosols ne dit pas c'est que la
biomasse est incroyablement destructrice
ce n'est pas une énergie verte et elle
ne devrait pas être considérée comme
renouvelable
confronter l'autorité
[Musique]
les écologistes luttent contre Drax
depuis des années l'usine brûlait du
charbon en crachant du carbone quand le
Royaume-Uni c'est engagé à abandonner
l'exploitation du charbon tout semblait
fini pour drags jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait
une substitution remplacer le charbon
par le bois et qualifiez cela d'énergie
verte
le changement climatique est le plus
grand défi de notre époque et Drax a un
rôle crucial à jouer dans la lutte
contre ce phénomène
l'argument écologique central de Drax
les arbres repoussent mais pas les
combustibles fossiles
notre biomasse provient de forêt gérer
durablement on dit que c'est une énergie
renouvelable parce qu'il suffit de
planter un arbre pour que le puit de
carbone se reconstitue
et
suffisant pour dire que cette énergie
est renouvelable
ce n'est pas une vision sérieuse de la
crise climatique
lorsque vous brûlez un arbre et que vous
le replantez il faut entre 44 et 104 ans
pour que les arbres replantés ou la
forêt replantée en monoculture absorbe
le carbone c'est illusoire de dire que
c'est renouvelable
mais l'argument de Drax a convaincu le
gouvernement britannique qui la financé
en grande partie avec l'argent des
contribuables Drax reçoit plus de 3
millions de dollars de subventions par
jour soit plus de 11 milliards jusqu'à
maintenant elle est même côté dans
l'indice boursier standard and Poels des
énergies propres si on prend ce statut
vert et qu'on y ajoute les subventions
vertes qu'obtient-on des profits pour
les actionnaires de Dax
et aujourd'hui nous allons sont un
dividende intérimaire de 40% de ce
montant soit 20 millions
rejoignent dans un pub des hommes et des
femmes impliquées dans la campagne axe
drops
il est très très difficile d'affronter
une crise climatique d'une telle
profondeur et d'une telle ampleur nous
n'avons pas de milliards nous n'avons
pas de société de relation publique mais
ce que nous pouvons faire c'est
comprendre la science s'informer et agir
d'une manière appropriée face à
l'urgence de la crise que nous
traversons actuellement
de livres par jour pour brûler des
arbres imaginez ce que vous pourriez
faire avec 2 millions de livres par jour
en investissant dans le solaire dans
l'éolien et en étant créatif avec cet
argentanismes qui nous aident à capturer
le dioxyde de carbone dans l'atmosphère
c'est totalement insensé
mais alors comment expliquer qu'un
processus qui brûle des arbres et qui
émet du carbone dans l'atmosphère puisse
être considéré comme carbone neutre et
l'énergie produite renouvelables où est
la logique vous cherchez la logique mais
ça n'a aucun sens il n'y a en fait
aucune logique fondamentale dans tout ça
parce qu'il y a une faille dans la loi
européenne qui n'oblige pas à faire de
déclarations
cette faille date de 1997 le Canada et
le Royaume-Uni faisaient partie des
signataires d'un accord historique sur
le suivi des émissions de carbone à
l'échelle mondiale mais lorsqu'il s'agit
d'arbres les émissions de carbone ne
sont comptabilisées que lorsque l'arbre
est abattu est transporté ce qui
signifie que des pays comme le
Royaume-Uni qui ne font que brûler le
bois non pas à faire ce calcul et c'est
une erreur selon les scientifiques le
problème c'est que dans les pays qui
brûlent de la biomasse les émissions
dues à la combustion ne sont absolument
pas comptabilisés dans leur compte
travaille au sein du groupe de réflexion
londoniens
de la combustion de granulés de bois au
Royaume-Uni dont la plupart proviennent
de Drax nous avons estimé que cela
équivalait aux émissions de 6 à 7
millions de véhicules
brûler du bois est-ce mieux que du
charbon non si vous brûlez du bois en
présence d'oxygène cela génère plus de
dioxyde de carbone par une unité
d'énergie produite que si vous brûlez
presque tous les types de charbon
il n'est pas le seul universitaire en
arrivait à cette conclusion en 2021 plus
de 500 économistes et scientifiques ont
signé cette lettre provenant des
universités de Princeton Oxford
Cambridge mais aussi du Canada pour
demander la fin des subventions pour les
granulés de bois selon eux la combustion
du bois est une fausse solution à la
crise climatique et les arbres sont plus
précieux vivants que morts autant pour
le climat que pour la biodiversité
nous commençons à voir des failles
apparaître
il y a plus de conscience et plus de
politiciens prêt à dire que c'est une
erreur
l'an passé drague a été retiré de
l'indice des énergies propres
en nous dernier le secrétaire à
l'énergie à lui-même exprimé des doutes
quant à cette industrie les actions de
drague ont chuté de 11%
. des députés de tout parti confondus
ont rédigé une lettre dans laquelle il
qualifie de scandale le fait de brûler
les arbres et remettez en question les
subventions versées à Drax Berry
gordiner était l'un d'eux
il faut tout simplement avouer que nous
nous sommes trompés ne nous laissons pas
berner par la biomasse durable ce n'est
pas durable il ne faut pas jouer sur les
mots ce n'est pas durable
un message pour les élus de la
Colombie-Britannique
est un lieu si magnifique et que dire de
la faune c'est un désastre il faut que
cela cesse il faut arrêter cette coupe à
blanc arrêtez l'industrie de la biomasse
dans son élan
toutes ces critiques n'ont pas échappé à
la tension de Drax dans un rapport
destiné aux actionnaires Drax met en
garde contre le risque que ces
détenteurs les écologistes influencent
les politiciens ce qui entraînerait une
baisse de soutien à l'industrie
pour atténuer ce risque croissant drags
déclare entre NIR de solides relations
avec des représentants du gouvernement y
compris au Canada
les industries du bois et de la biomasse
sont une certaine influence sur les
gouvernements en particulier dans les
pays où ces industries sont importantes
comme le Canada comme le Canada et en
Europe les pays nordiques ou encore le
Royaume-Uni en avril 2022 Drax déclare
être ravi d'accueillir une nouvelle
membre au sein de son équipe de
direction La Forestière en chef de la
Colombie-Britannique Diane Nichols Drax
n'a pas souhaité accorder d'entrevue
lors du tournage en Angleterre nos
collègues souhaitaient rencontrer Madame
Nicoz c'est la personne à qui nous
aimerions parler nous souhaiterions la
rencontrer en Colombie-Britannique
après la pause l'équipe journalistique
va se rendre dans une zone de coupe à
blanc et avoir toute une surprise
l'industrie des granulés de bois était
censé utiliser les résidus forestiers
ici
[Musique]
Drax rapporte de l'argent beaucoup
d'argent la Colombie-Britannique mais il
y a des élus qui disent qu'on y perd au
change et que ça n'a pas de sens de
couper des arbres et d'en faire des
granulés
[Musique]
la centrale électrique Drax a besoin de
beaucoup de bois chaque jour 20 000
tonnes de granulés sont livrés et
servent de combustible pour la
production d'électricité
[Musique]
s
permettent de conserver au sec les
granulés de bois chaque jour 14
livraisons par train alimentent la
centrale ces trains transportent des
granulés de bois provenant des forêts du
monde entier que ce soit du Brésil de
l'Estonie des États-Unis et de la
Colombie-Britannique dans le port de
Prince Rupert un nouveau terminal a même
été construit spécialement pour les
granulés de bois qui ne sont plus
destinés uniquement à l'Angleterre
Drax exporte dorénavant les granulés de
la Colombie Britannique au Japon et en
Corée du Sud
dans un rapport aux actionnaires la
compagnie indique qu'elle opère dans des
régions de la Colombie-Britannique qui
comprennent des forêts anciennes cette
industrie est soutenue par le
gouvernement
[Musique]
à Victoria un membre de l'Assemblée
législative s'oppose au soutien du
gouvernement
le soutien du gouvernement à la
compagnie Drax ne fait qu'aggraver la
crise des forêts en Colombes britannique
le gouvernement de la Colombie
Britannique et pris en otage par cette
industrie
nous continuons à couper de façon non
durable en Colombie-Britannique au
profit
il suffit de survoler la province pour
se rendre compte de ce qui s'est passé
au fil des décennies
[Musique]
détient des preuves que les fabricants
de granulés de bois exploitent les
arbres entiers de forêt primaire elle a
mis une carte en ligne
ce site a été exploité il y a plus d'un
an
c'est un bloc de coupe qui a été
exploité par la compagnie pinacle drags
il détenait une licence d'exploitation
voici à quoi ressemblait cette montagne
en 2019 la forêt primaire était intacte
et voici à quoi elle ressemble un an
plus tard
la forêt a été exploitée par la
compagnie pinacle drags le bois était
transformé en granulés et expédié aux
Atlantique
cette forêt a été coupée afin
d'alimenter temporairement des
ordinateurs portables ou des iPhone
un seul arbre est encore debout tout le
reste a disparu les fabricants de
granulés de bois affirment ne prendre
ici que les billots de moindre qualité
les troncs plus grandes valeurs sont
vendues à des séries et d'autres
manufacturiers en 2021 Pinnacle qui a
été racheté par Drax a versé au
gouvernement de la Colombie-Britannique
plus de 2 millions de dollars pour
abattre ses arbres
l'équipe de CBC entame une longue montée
vers le sommet
en haut elle trouve un tas de cime
d'arbre de branches et même des troncs
entiers
[Musique]
l'industrie des granulés de bois était
censé utiliser les résidus forestiers
ici je l'ignore je suis aussi surprise
que vous
c'est tas de débris ce n'est qu'un
gâchis
enfin ils ont pris les troncs et laissez
les résidus c'est même résidus
forestiers que l'industrie des granulés
de bois affirmait justement vouloir
exploiter souvenez-vous de leur vidéo
nous utilisons également les résidus
forestiers comme les branches ou les
cimes laissées après l'abattage et de ce
que Drax déclarait il s'agit de résidus
laissés dans la forêt ou qui proviennent
des séries de la grande industrie du
sillage
avant l'industrie des granulés dans
l'ouest du Canada une grande partie de
ces déchets a été brûlée sur le bord des
routes c'était le grand argument de
drague comme on peut le voir dans leur
vidéo dans la pratique courante
l'exploitation forestière brûle ce qui
reste sur le site alors que l'industrie
des granulés de bois est essenti
résoudre ce problème en transformant ces
résidus en granulés pour les expédiés à
l'étranger
ces entreprises affirment être vertes et
durables
mais ce n'est qu'un énorme mensonge
l'usine de granulés de bois à métaux
Bank se trouve à 45 minutes de route au
sud de prince Georges dragues en a fait
l'acquisition l'an passé l'équipe a
tenté d'obtenir une entrevue avec Drax
pendant des semaines l'entreprise a
finalement ouvert ses portes à nos
collègues de CBC pour une visite du site
avec le directeur de la durabilité
joachino
[Musique]
en quoi brûler des granulés de bois
provenant de forêt est bon pour
l'environnement
quand on regarde d'où ça vient notre
matière première vient de la forêt et
n'a pas d'autre utilité que d'être
brûlées
environ 80% de la matière utilisée pour
fabriquer des granulés de bois provient
de résidus de série c'est ce que vous
voyez ici et environ 20% de la matière
première provient des forêts que ce soit
sous forme de Boiron ou de copeaux de
bois
des copeaux de bois qui sont faits avec
quelle partie des arbres il s'agit
essentiellement de résidus
d'exploitation forestière entassées sur
le bord de la route c'est ce qu'on
appelle les résidus de coupe en bord de
route ce sont les cimes les branches les
parties inutilisables que l'industrie du
siège a rejeté ce sont principalement
des matières résiduelles
j'aimerais vous montrer quelque chose
sur cet écran j'ai les numéros
spécifiques dans mon téléphone
ce sont des résidus de coupe oui
l'équipe montre à Monsieur akinos qu'ils
ont vu dans cette zone de coupable ces
mêmes tas de résidus forestier que Drax
affirme transformer en granulés de bois
d'État laissé sur place après avoir
récolté les troncs
le numéro de bloc est à 9 5 7
et voici les coordonnées GPS
mais cela il ne le disent pas dans leur
vidéo à ce jour CBC n'a pas eu de retour
concernant ce site
la plupart de ces résidus ne sont pas
ramassés tout simplement parce que c'est
trop coûteux pour Pinnacle ouraxe
une grande partie des résidus forestiers
transformés dans les installations de
Dax sont en fait des troncs entiers
drague ça fait savoir publiquement
qu'elle souhaitait augmenter sa capacité
de production au Canada en Colombie
Britannique dans le but d'ajouter un
autre de mes millions de tonnes de
production par an
les images des tas de résidus ont été
montrés au maire de kennel Bob Simpson
c'est un peu ironique que l'industrie
des granulés de bois qui a été développé
pour éliminer le problème adopte ce même
comportement dans la forêt ces
déplorable à bien des niveaux
les couples blanchiment de l'industrie
des granulés de bois doit cesser
ouvrons-nous les yeux c'est une machine
qui rapporte beaucoup d'argent à
quelques personnes grâce aux subventions
du Royaume-Uni et aux dépens de la
Colombie Britannique
après la pause Drax a une nouvelle
responsable de la durabilité pour
l'Amérique du Nord une femme qui a
d'excellents contacts là où ça compte
chaque fois qu'un bureau crate fait le
saut pour aller travailler au sein d'une
industrie sur laquelle il s'est penché
et qu'il a soutenu
et je dirais pour être poli que c'est un
peu troublant
plutôt dans ce reportage on vous parlait
de Diane Nichols la Forestière en chef
de la Colombie-Britannique c'est elle
qui pendant de nombreuses années était
responsables de la gestion de la forêt
et bien elle a un nouvel emploi
devinez où
pour produire de l'électricité la
centrale drags a besoin de plus en plus
de bois provenant des forêts
britanniques colombiennes Drax possède 8
usines de granulés de bois dans la
province c'est le plus grand acteur
d'une industrie qui dépend de la coupe à
blanc de ce qu'elle appelle les résidus
forestiers les cicatrices de ces coupes
sont visibles depuis l'espace
nous sommes sur le point de perdre ses
forêts elles sont littéralement sur le
point d'être entièrement détruite
Theresa Ryan est chargé de cours
département de foresterie de
l'Université de la Colombie-Britannique
elle fait partie du projet mother three
de l'université
[Musique]
s
de rétention
si c'est une façon durable d'exploiter
les forêts pourquoi on ne le fait pas
le système n'est pas fait pour ça
il est conçu avec la mentalité coloniale
d'appropriation en se disant que les
ressources sont inépuisables que c'est
la rue et vers l'or
c'est ça la mentalité le but est de
générer des revenus pour le gouvernement
et de faire des profits
qu'il faut cesser la coupe à blanc ça ne
fait plus aucun doute c'est la priorité
parce que la forêt ne peut pas se
reconstituer
je ne suis pas contre l'exploitation
forestière mais selon moi elle pourrait
être faite d'une bien meilleure manière
d'une façon bien plus valorisante que ce
qui est fait actuellement
[Musique]
des granulés de bois a besoin de ses
copains pour survivre
on ne parle pas d'un gros arbre ici et
là
on parle de forêt entière dans sauteur
de strings
tout un écosystème forestier et
ce n'est pas une industrie durable
c'était une forêt dense
cherche aussi des solutions ce député
libéral de Prince George est aussi
trappeur il conduit l'équipe sur une
zone de coupe à blanc qui selon lui fait
à peu près la superficie de la ville de
Vancouver soit une centaine de
kilomètres carrés
il faudra des décennies avant que
l'habitat accueille la moindre marque ou
le moindre Pékin où tout autre vie
sauvage
c'est triste et c'est à l'échelle de la
province
réclame une révision complète de la
gestion des forêts en
Colombie-Britannique
c'était un sapin un sapin de grande
taille
nous avons besoin d'une modification de
la législation nous devons éliminer les
pratiques d'exploitation forestière
basées sur le volume et introduire des
pratiques écologiques afin que toutes
les valeurs du sol soient prises en
compte quand nous décidons quels arbres
doivent être abattus et quels arbres ne
doivent pas l'être selon moi il y aura
très peu d'exploitations forestières
dans cette province dans les 30 ou 50
prochaines années parce que nous avons
tout simplement trop exploité
c'est intéressant de voir comment le
gouvernement provincial présente sa
gestion des forêts
est-elle gérée comme la forêt la plus
durable du monde est-ce que le
gouvernement provincial la gère de
manière durable non pas du tout ils en
sont très loin
l'industrie forestière elle-même et les
gouvernements de tous les partis ont par
leur mauvaise gestion depuis les 75
dernières années
perpétuer ce mythe en
Colombie-Britannique Le Forestier en
chef travaille en étroite collaboration
avec le gouvernement il décide de ce qui
peut être coupé à blanc et quand
jusqu'en avril 2022 Daniel Nicos
conseillère au gouvernement Orgun était
la Forestière en chef
au printemps dernier madame Nicos a
quitté le plus haut poste de gestion des
forêts de la Colombie-Britannique et
elle est aujourd'hui vice-présidente et
responsable de la durabilité du groupe
Drax en Amérique du Nord
qu'est-ce que ça nous dit sur la
relation entre le gouvernement et
l'industrie dans cette
provinceau combien ils sont proches
et cela prouve
que les priorités ne sont pas les bonnes
nos collègues souhaitent s'entretenir
avec Madame Nicos au sujet des décisions
qu'elle a prises en tant que forestière
en chef pendant presque 10 ans elle dit
ne pas pouvoir en parler sauf si son
nouvel emploier le lui permet
Drax a décliné la demande d'entrevue
mais on autorise des causes à s'adresser
à l'association des manufacturiers de
granulés de bois lors de l'assemblée
annuelle c'est une occasion pour
l'industrie d'échanger avec les
fonctionnaires provinciaux de la forêt
et ces drags qui financent la réception
l'équipe a obtenu l'autorisation
d'assister au discours de sa chaîne
les organisateurs informent l'équipe
plus tard qu'elle a annulée à la
dernière minute dans un récent courriel
drague sa confirmé que d'un Écosse
n'accorderait pas d'entrevue
chaque fois qu'un bureau gratte fais le
saut pour aller travailler au sein d'une
industrie sur laquelle il s'est penché
et qu'il a soutenu
et je dirais pour être poli que c'est un
peu troublant et dans ce cas-ci quel
serait le terme impoli
je dirais scandaleux selon moi ça mérite
une enquête
John organe qui était premier ministre
au moment du tournage a refusé
d'accorder une entrevue à nos collègues
Catherine conraï alors ministre des
forêts a déclaré par voie de communiquer
que daen Nichols a joué un rôle
déterminant dans la nouvelle aire de
planification de la gestion forestière
et à défendu l'industrie des granulés de
bois et la firme que le secteur des
granulés de bois de la
Colombie-Britannique a contribué à
réduire les déchets de l'industrie
forestière et garantit que les déchets
de chaque arbre abattu sont utilisés en
nous dernier dragste a acheté une autre
usine de granulés de bois en
Colombie-Britannique dans le cadre d'un
ambitieux plan visant à atteindre une
production annuelle de 8 millions de
tonnes d'ici 2030
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez apprécié le
reportage de ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
je vous donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour une autre enquête
[Musique]